[Musique]
la shadoks caravelle poursuit l'astro
lune le marin essaie d'attraper les
shadoks
on ne sait pas encore où juste pourquoi
faire l'achat d'une caravelle faisait
merveille la plus tranchante régnait à
vauré chacun sous caire il faut dire que
la marine shadoks était un bel exemple
d'organisation
tout le monde était spécialisé les uns
étaient spécialisés dans le ramage les
autres et est spécialisée dans le
transport table de l'eau et tout le
monde était content
tout le monde était contre eux sauf
peut-être ceux qui étaient spécialisés
dans le battage c'était sûr qu'on t'a
fait quand le marin avec des finitions à
distribuer c'était pénible évidemment
mais c'était indispensable pour
maintenir le combat de l'équipage car
disait-il dans la marine c'est un
principe pour qu'il y ait le moins de
mécontents possible il faut toujours
taper sur les mêmes
c'est pourquoi il avait formé un corps
spécial le corps des shadoks à claques
envers lesquels il faisait très
habituellement preuve de la plus exquise
brutalité alors non mais et c est bête
là vous couvrirez hills écoles de tout
ça finit toujours par s'user le corps
d'élite les shadoks à claques n'était
plus très présentable et il fallait
procéder à un échange standard
voilà pourquoi il voulait les attraper
les shadoks de la lune
engagez-vous dans les shadows 4-lat il
criait vous verrez du pays mais les
autres voulaient pas pensé et s'en
faisait tant qu'arme cette sarabande
autour de la
d'abord c'était la lune qui passe est un
grassement chaque minute après c'était
le marin et puis encore la lune et puis
encore le marin ça n'allait pas bientôt
finir tout ce raffut il criait gêne on
n'avait pas aidé il s'amusait la nuit à
des bêtises pareilles
d'abord il avait commencé par balles a
dit la lune dans le ciel de la semaine
dernière c'étaient des haricots il est
maintenant c'était des bateaux et demain
ça serait quoi encore pas le lendemain
mais cinq minutes après c'est et des
autobus qui lui passait sur la tête un
jet parce que les shadows avait rien
prouvé nul que dati leur mieux comme
autobus à la somme était trop dès demain
s'était juré il débarrasserait le ciel
de toutes ces cochonneries tard
[Musique]
m